[Music]
on average each day I tend to get at
least one question that's asked of me in
YouTube or some other format Facebook
Twitter that could very easily be
answered by the question or simply by
doing a little bit of internet research
which is enabled by the wonderful search
engines that we have not only through
Google but on almost every site so I
thought I would create this standard
response video in which I could say
listen why don't you just search for it
and give a few guidelines about that
talk about the nature of search and and
how I understand that you know it may be
natural to want to throw these these
questions and comments out there but why
it's a little bit counterproductive so
what sorts of questions are we talking
about I get them most frequently on my
YouTube videos and there'll be things
like hey do you have any videos on
so-and-so or have you ever written about
this sort of thing or can you direct me
to other etc etc etc and I also get them
on my blog posts in facebook both on
posts and indirect messages same thing
with Twitter occasionally in Google+
occasionally in LinkedIn so this video
is going to be quite useful there's
there's a wide range of stuff that I
think people could so easily
just search themselves I know that I
risk coming across as a curmudgeonly old
figure in in saying why don't you just
google it or you know there are search
functions out there that you can use but
there there is a reason why I thought
this is actually worth talking about and
really it comes down to two different
things
one is that if you're just asking people
for information that you could so easily
acquire yourself you're not building up
the kind of habits and you're actually
building counterproductive habits
for what we can call the internet
environment and an age that we're not
going to exit from unless you know
there's some global catastrophe this is
gonna be more and more part of our life
so it's what we call information
literacy which is not just you know
knowing like how to parse information
it's knowing where to go for quality
information so you know this is very
very basic stuff if you want to know in
YouTube for example what's available in
any given persons channel you can search
within that channel you can also you
know use various tags to search a
variety of different channels it's very
easy to do those who want to know more
about my my work can easily just type in
Gregory B Sadler into Google and all
sorts of sites come up including you
know my my facebook page my academia.edu
where you can see all of my academic
writings you know people ask do you have
a business well just again Google
Gregory B Sadler reason IO comes up
right do you do this sort of thing well
go to the site and search around within
the site same thing with the blog's do
you have a blog entry about this you
know you look on blogs and you see down
the side there's all these topics you
click on those or just use the search
function right this is this is very
important for people to learn and I
understand that you know there are some
users who because of the equipment that
they've got or the training that they've
had might not know how to do this but
it's really really to your advantage to
know how to carry out searches
effectively and efficiently because it
opens up an entire world for you and
knowing then how to aggregate stuff is
also really important as well so I think
that I do want to stress that if you are
like writing an author and asking do you
have any books about XYZ and you're not
just looking on say Amazon or Google to
find that out or if you're going to a
YouTube video producer and saying you
haven't
about XYZ and you're not looking say
through their playlists or even is using
the search function your shortchanging
yourself
you know and that doesn't mean that you
can't you know start a conversation in
so many other ways with somebody who who
you liked maybe you're posting it
because you hope you get a conversation
going you know it's better to be
well-informed and then start the
conversation so that brings me to my
second point about this which is that
you know if I had infinite time I might
actually be inclined to answer all of
those sorts of enquiries instead of just
saying listen you can search that do it
yourself right but I don't and and my
activity as a producer of content is
dependent on those same 24 hours that
everybody in the world gets and you know
I'm also in my middle age so I see that
horizon of what I'd like to get done
getting closer and closer and closer as
as I age as well so I don't really have
the time to walk people to be the sort
of information repository about what I
what I have available I've already done
the work to organize my videos into
playlists to you know do the tagging in
blogs for you know subject lines and all
of that to make my website manageable so
you know it's up to the the person on
the other end to do the work to walk
through it and I simply don't have the
available time to devote to each person
asking me questions about you know do
you have this do you have that do you of
this because that takes away from from
the thought and time and and work that I
do that got you thinking you should ask
me a question in the first place so
hopefully when you see this if you've
actually watched this to the end your
response is not that sob Sadler he
should have answered my question but
rather oh yeah I can answer my own
questions and that's empowering and
that's gonna help me out and then you
know you can come and ask me more
in-depth questions later on once you've
figured out what you
want to talk about her want to research
about
[Music]